[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Well hello everyone.
My name's Yukio Lippit and
I'm the faculty Director
of the Arts at the
Radcliffe Institute.
And it's a real pleasure to
welcome you to this occasion.
The opening of the exhibition
by Wendy Jacob, titled Calm.
Smoke Rises Vertically, in
Radcliffe's Johnson-Kulakundis
Family Gallery.
Now Wendy Jacob is a
widely admired artist
who bridges many practices.
Among them, the practices
of architecture,
sculpture, design, invention.
She was based in
Chicago for many years
where she received her MFA from
the Art Institute of Chicago,
and where she was a founding
member of the art collective,
Haha, that was
formed there in 1988,
and worked together
for some two decades.
Haha is widely acclaimed for
developing an art practice that
really pushed at many of the
boundaries of what art could be
and who had access to it.
It's many projects, which
included all kinds of community
based projects, sculptural
installations, video work,
and so forth, tended in
their words, to be ephemeral.
Closely interwoven with
the times and places
where they were
shown and addressed
the particulars of living
in it locally and centrally
embedded situation.
Now in addition to
her work with Haha,
Jacob also developed her
own artistic projects
that explored among other
things, the relationships
between architecture and
perceptual experience.
The interface
between architecture
and the bodies of the
peoples and animals
inhabiting the
built environment.
And in this regard,
Jacob has been
the consummate
collaborator who's
worked in a collective
with other artists.
But also with architects,
engineers, researchers
in various fields
over the years,
really yielding a long list of
solo exhibitions, publications,
and residencies, nationally
and internationally, too
numerous to enumerate here.
Although I should be
remiss not to mention
that she was formerly a fellow
at the Radcliffe institute
in the year 2005.
One of her more
well-known collaborations
was with Temple Grandin,
the animal scientist who
has written widely on autism,
and catalyzed by conversations
with Grandin, Jacob
developed the squeeze chair,
which consists of a
series of chairs really,
with arms that inflate to
hold the sitter in a firm hug.
It takes its cue from the
fact that many with autism
are especially receptive to the
calming effects of pressure.
In 2006, Jacob founded
the autism studio
at MIT, a multi-disciplinary
studio that
aims to explore perceptual
features afforded
by the broad range of
autistic experience
and to create objects
and spaces and events
that really resonated
with these experiences.
More recently, over
the past two years,
Jacob has worked with the
Cherry Road Resource Center
for the Disabled in
Scotland to understand,
among other things, the nature
of the tactility of sound
for the hearing impaired.
Now the exhibition
that opens today, Calm.
Smoke Rises Vertically,
really extends
in new ways, the
vectors of inquiry
that Jacob has been
pursuing over the years.
Most notably, here
interest in expanding
the sensory dimensions of art.
In the Johnson-Kulakundis
Gallery,
10 architectural models are
displayed in combination
with meteorological
information, which
is played through the
walls of the gallery.
And both the models
and the weather
reports, convey
empirical knowledge that,
by calibrating a
verbal description
to sensory experience.
The architectural models
displayed in the gallery
are on loan from the
Perkins School for the Blind
and the Ohio State
School for the Blind.
They have an
interesting history.
They were created between
the years 1935 in 1943,
under the auspices of the
WPA, the Works Progress
Administration, which
mobilized many craftsmen
and specialists to create
tactile models for.
blind students.
The models were intended
to convey knowledge
about architecture through
touch, allowing blind students
to see them for the first time.
The weather reports which are
conveyed through the walls,
include a live streaming of the
weather broadcast of the NOAA.
Also live sounds from outdoors
and a reading of the Beaufort
Wind Scale.
The Beaufort Wind
Scale is a scale
that was developed in
the early 19th century
to match a defined set
of verbal descriptions
to approximate wind speeds, with
the practical aim of allowing
users to, on land
or sea, to quantify
the observable
conditions around them.
And so for example, a 4
on the Beaufort Scale,
which is a brisk
breeze is indicated
by the phrase small trees
and leaf begin to sway.
So the title of the
exhibition Calm.
Smoke Rises Vertically
describes a wind speed
of less than one knot.
Now the exhibition highlights
in a wonderful way,
the correspondences between
the tactile models and weather
reports, in order to
underscore the ways in which
perceptual experiences
through different senses
reinforce and
transform one another.
In the models, touching
is synonymous with seeing.
Whereas in the weather
reports, the invisible,
the wind is rendered
comprehensible.
And by playing the
weather reports
through the walls of the
gallery, Jacob in essence,
transforms the gallery
walls themselves,
into large surfaces of sound.
Speakers of sound
thus generating
an equivalence again
between its tactility,
and that of the models.
Now although we live in an age
of the lab, the model it seems
for all forms of
innovative research,
especially at a university,
including artistic research,
one might say that
Wendy Jacob is
an artist of a different kind.
One who belongs to
something like The Club.
Fundamentally collaborative
and egalitarian,
as suggested by one of her
recent projects, the Explorers
Club.
Her work is characterized
by a great deal of empathy,
but not necessarily
only for the so-called
disabled peoples and
communities with whom she works.
But really her
empathy is directed
at the rest of humanity
which is missing out
on so much rich
sensation and attunement
to one's surroundings.
In her interdisciplinary
approach
and relentless plumbing of
different spheres of knowing,
her aims seem to
resonate so well
with the aims of the Radcliffe
institute as a whole.
And it is a real privilege
to be able to work
with her on this occasion.
Now this exhibition
was organized
by the academic ventures
division of the Radcliffe
Institute in conjunction with
the Radcliffe Arts Program.
And on behalf of
our Dean, Liz Cohen,
our Director of Academic
Ventures, Becky Wasserman,
Jennifer [? Burkitt ?]
and others
at Academic Ventures, Meg
Rotzel our arts program manager.
Joe Zane, our proprietor
and our colleagues
in facilities communications
events, the Fellows Program.
I'd like to say a few
thank yous and we'd
like to convey a heartfelt
thanks to the Perkins
School for the Blind, and
in particular to Betsy
[? Senate, ?] the curator
of the tactile museum there,
who was a really
generous collaborator
and helped enable this
exhibition and the loans
to our gallery.
As well as the Ohio State
School for the Blind and Cecilia
Peirano and Laurie Kaplan there.
They again, greeted this
project with so much support
and enthusiasm.
We'd also like to thank our
friends at the National Rail
Press.
And also to thank
Lilly [? Shirless ?]
who was an undergraduate
at Harvard College, who
served as Wendy's assistant
and whose competence
and formidable research
skills were also essential
in enabling the show.
Last but not least,
we'd like to thank
Wendy Jacob herself,
a collaborator
in the true sense of the word.
An artist who has taught
us a great deal as someone
who is kind of constantly full
of remarkable observations
that make you see
daily life around you
in new and meaningful ways.
Now for our panel discussion, in
addition to the artist herself,
we'll be joined by
Hansel Bauman who
is practicing architect and
founding partner of Hansel
Bauman Architect and Planner,
as well as university architect
and executive director of
campus design and construction
at Gallaudet University
in Washington DC.
In 2006, he founded the
Death Space Project.
He's a recognized leader
in architectural design
that enhances cultural
and sensory experiences
and was lectured and published
widely on architecture,
the senses, and disability.
And was a 2015, recipient
of the Gold Award
from the International
Association
of Universal Design.
Our other panelist
is Kim Charlson
who has been the director of the
library at the Perkins School
for the Blind since 2001.
She is a distinguished expert
on library and information
services for people
with disabilities.
Charlson is widely
published and serves
on several committees for the
Library of Congress' National
Library Service, and for
the Blind and Physically
Handicapped.
She is the first woman president
of the American Council
of the blind.
It's hard to think of two more
distinguished interlocutors
to discuss our exhibition today.
So please join me in
welcoming them now.
- Thank you, Yukio.
I just wanted to add a
few thank yous of my own
and I wanted in addition,
to Yukio who has been just
really wonderful to work with,
and Rebecca, and Jennifer
[? Burkitt ?] and Meg
Rotzel, the gallery director.
Who also spent hours cleaning
these models with a Q-Tip
and Joe Zane who excavated
the gallery walls to install
transducers inside them.
And again Lily [? Shirless ?]
the excellent research
assistant, and then
graduate students,
Georgia [? Kenichi ?] and
[? Kyoto ?] [? Kaseki ?]
and Faith [? Maclure, ?]
who also spent long,
patient hours
cleaning with Q-Tips.
And [? Virad ?] [? Chukla ?] and
Will [? Mentor ?] for help with
production of the Model.
And Cecilia Peirano who
came here from Ohio.
And finally, I want to
express my appreciation
to all the unknown craftsmen
of the WPA era, who produced
these models, and for the
statesmen and stateswomen
of that progressive era who had
the vision to Commission them.
- Great well let's
dive right in.
You know many times Wendy,
during the preparations
for the show, you've
mentioned that you've really
taken some of your
cues for this project
and for your vectors
of inquiry in general
from the architecture for the
Perkins School for the Blind,
which is just next
door in Watertown Mass.
And I was wondering if you
could elaborate a little bit
upon what it is about
the architecture
and the environment there, that
has been so catalytic for you.
- I think this is something
that the three of us share.
I think four years
ago Hansel and I
took a tour of the Perkins
School in Watertown.
And what I think most amazed
us was the old building,
the old Victorian
buildings where
they're really built to
give you a sense of where
you are in space.
For example, the
floors are tiled,
but when you had
a cross-section,
the ceiling is higher and so the
echo of your footfall changes.
And so you know that
you've hit an intersection.
And one of the most beautiful
and subtle aspects of it
is that the floors are slightly
tilted, really, very slightly
tilted, so that if you're
walking against the tilt
you know you're going
on a straight line.
If you start to go uphill or
downhill you're going zigzag.
And when we were there,
we went into the basement
where we discovered
this amazing collection
of tactile objects, which
included the buildings, some
of which are here.
But it also includes a taxidermy
shark and a bear and a rocket
ship and it's like a
cabinet of curiosities.
- Well Yeah, I guess on
that same tour, to me
I think, kind of seeing that
building through Wendy's eyes
really was very, really
quite an experience,
because I think it was
intentionally designed
acoustically, like
Wendy's explained.
I think there was also
another layer of design
about that building
that I think we often
forget, that newly
started me thinking
about the idea of materiality.
Because it's a stone Collegiate
Gothic building that not only,
do you begin to have
the kind of resonance
from acoustics from that
stone, but you could almost
begin to feel pressure from it.
The weight of the
wall in that space,
you could really begin
to sense the difference
or if a wood wall is next
to you or if a heavy stone
wall is next to you.
Or because of the
vibration, you can really
begin to tell that the
scale of the space.
So that building really, in some
ways, reached out and touched
you in a way that
I don't think I've
ever experienced in
a building before.
For me that opens up a whole
new question about how we really
do experience space, far beyond
our obsessions as architects
is what they look like.
- So I have the opportunity
to work with these folks
and be a part of this panel.
And one of the joys
about doing this
is, because I walk through
those halls every day.
And sometimes I don't think
about what they really mean.
And to talk to Wendy and
Hansel about how much they
gain from walking in the
halls of the Howe Building
at Perkins, really made
me appreciate them.
And kind of go back
and think about well,
these are the halls
I walk all the time.
But what do they mean?
And they do have
a sensory meaning.
And they really
do bring out what
I think is a often
under utilized
sense for blind or
visually impaired people.
Which is really kind of feeling
and communing with the building
you're in.
And it sounds a little
woohoo, to that talk
about something like this.
But in fact, you may just
think about it yourselves.
You may have been in a
building where part of it
felt really cold.
But then you might be
walking down the hall
and there's other
parts that are warm,
or that sound from the high
ceiling to the more tightly
closed, or the wooden walls.
You can pick up so many cues and
so many clues from the building
itself.
And I think that's what's
really exciting about Wendy's
work and the whole idea of
thinking about buildings
as places that are
communicating to you as well,
and delivering a message.
The Perkins Buildings are
symmetrical on both sides.
So back in the day when they
were built in 1912 or so,
you know they had a side
for girls and this for boys.
And so everything is
identical on both sides.
And it was very thoughtfully
designed that way.
But there are so many clues.
And I think one thing,
when you experience
the exhibit today, the
one thing that you really
need to put aside is that
old mantra of do not touch.
Because this is an exhibit
where you're really
encouraged to touch
and to feel and to feel
the smoothness and the roughness
or whatever in the models
that you're looking at.
it's a multi-sensory
experience that I
think will be just fascinating
and really inspiring
for all of you to take
full advantage of.
- Yeah could we talk
a little bit more
about this idea of
tactile engagement
with your surroundings and with
objects and ways of acquiring
knowledge about them.
Because that is something that
there is a kind of very strong
I think, inhibition
against doing,
once you enter a gallery or
museum space and something
that we will try to overcome
in encouraging people
to interact with the objects.
We have taboos against
touching, operating in society
that very much
condition the way we
engage an event
like an art viewing.
- To me what's fascinating
about what you'll see tonight
is, the walls that you'll kind
of move up against and start
to touch and put your ear to
and really engage that wall.
I think that again, goes
back to an invitation
to have a relationship
or think about buildings
in a completely different way.
Then I think, typically
we think of them
as objects and things that
are separate from ourselves.
And I think that's a
very detrimental way
for all of us to think about
the spaces that we inhabit.
Because that distance
is I think, sort of
at the core of why we
even have a sustainability
problem in the first place.
Because we in essence,
have sort of lost touch
with the very thing
that we create
to surround ourselves with.
A building is much like
a shell is to a mollusk.
How this building shares
and embraces my body,
it also embraces all of you.
And that kind of
shared embrace to me,
is what I started to
think a lot about when
I'm listening to that wall
and hearing the weather that's
taking place somewhere else.
So I think, looking at
that as an invitation,
and then over time, how
that touch will probably
soil that wall.
I think that that
to me, is going
to be really interesting to come
back at the end of the display
and begin to see the
markings of what got left,
and that kind of [INAUDIBLE]
set that that wall will take on
over time is also something
that's very interesting.
And invites us to think about
the life of the building
and how buildings
age just like we age.
And that there's grace
to that, and that's
what I'm hoping we as
architects will start
to pay more attention to,
rather than what it simply looks
like as an object.
- And Hansel and I have
had some conversations
about what are elements
of building design today.
Because he specializes in
kind of creating spaces
that are optimal for
deaf and hard of hearing.
And my interests in
accessibility and universal
design, talk about
using the building
and giving clues for
primarily, navigation.
That's always the
biggest challenge
for blind and visually impaired.
But lately, I've also
thought about sound and sound
absorption and sound
reflection, and how
that works in a building
and lighting as well.
Good lighting in a
building is incredibly
important to someone
who has low vision
and can utilize that vision.
It's also important to someone
who's deaf or hard of hearing,
because the better
the lighting is,
the better they're
going to perceive
the environment they're
in when they can't hear.
So we've had some
conversations about shared
environmental aspects of design
that really touch each other
and complement each
other in a way that
makes a building even more
universally usable for all.
- And to make the
walls even friendlier
to snuggle up against
or put your ear to.
We painted them
with milk paint, so
that even just an hour
after painting it,
there aren't any of
those noxious fumes
you associate with other paints.
So it's a very
subtle intervention,
but it makes a difference
in that moment.
- Now when you press here,
you're up against the wall,
you will hear again
the live sounds
from outdoors, the weather
report, and the Beaufort Wind
Scale.
And so you're really bringing
kind of weather and the climate
into the gallery.
Why weather?
Why this interest in
weather and in the climate?
- I was telling Yukio that
I just spent the last year
living in Glasgow, Scotland.
And everyone talks about
the weather all the time.
It's a big part of living
in Scotland, is the weather
and it's not like
always a bad thing.
It's just what you talk about.
And if it was sunny
for five days,
on the 6th day, everyone
talks about what a relief
it is that the air feels fresh.
Because it's raining.
And so, I was thinking
a lot about weather.
And also listening
to the BBC, they
have this shipping forecast.
Which is this old
forecast that people like
go to sleep listening to it.
It's really a much
loved forecast.
And they used the Beaufort Wind
Scale in the shipping forecast.
So I think we became
interested in that.
But I've also
interested in just what
is the climate or the
atmosphere for these houses?
And so, it's the weather
both and bringing it
in from outdoors and
creating its own climate
within the space.
- To build on that, I think
one of the things that
is also interesting
is again, how
contemporary that commentary is.
Positioning weather and
buildings is going back
to this idea, the building is
sort of a skin if you will.
As we've matured into the
whole era of sustainability,
we now have buildings where
windows don't necessarily open.
Mechanical systems are driving
the temperature of the room.
Often times acoustics,
this room actually
has really wonderful
acoustics, many times it's
hard to hear a speaker or
hard to hear yourself think,
because of the mechanical
systems are designed poorly.
We're completely separated
from that weather.
And somehow weather
has become a bad thing
or to have that permeable skin.
In the deaf community,
what that meant
was older buildings before
there was the existence of air
conditioning
systems or lighting,
buildings were much more
attuned to borrowing
those natural systems,
be it light or wind,
or even temperature.
And those then, gave buildings a
much more kind of navigability.
They gave them the
quality of light
was much better for
reading sign language.
We lost all of
that when we began
to introduce electric
light and air
conditioning into buildings.
Even room dimensions,
hallways were much wider
for the circulation and
stratification of air.
All of that changed as we
began to shrink buildings,
largely for control
of temperature.
So I think seeing these together
and seeing how weather is
our friend, like in Scotland.
Rainy is good.
I think there's a real
lesson to learn there
about how we think
about our environment
and where we think about
our own membrane is.
Is it another sweater?
Is it [INAUDIBLE]?
So I think again,
your work is really
an invitation to
think about buildings
in a really wonderful new way.
- And going back, I mean
it's going back in time
to the Howe Building
which is the main building
on the Perkins
campus where there's
these two long colonnades.
And along them they're
windows, so in the summertime
they were originally
all open, so
that as you walk
down the colonnade
you'd feel the
breeze on one cheek.
And so it would orient you.
You know where you are.
And I don't know if they're
still open in the summer.
- Yes, they still are.
- Good.
- We just finished
a renovation project
on one end of the Howe Building
to modernize it a little bit
and make it more
wheelchair accessible,
but that portion of the building
is still very much high windows
and very thick walls to keep
the cool in and the heat out
in the summer and vice versa.
So there's still a lot of
100-plus year-old architecture
that lives on every day.
- When I was in Ohio talking
with Celia at the Ohio State
School for the
Blind, she commented
that in one of the
classrooms, they
had rebuilt the windows
are really high,
and so the children
who were blind
had no idea what the
weather was outside.
And they'd have to ask her
well, what's going on outside?
And so it seemed really
important to bring the weather
in.
One of the interesting
things about the show
is the equivalence you
make between the models
and the gallery itself.
And of course, that's
underscored by the fact
that one of the
models in the show
is of the Johnson-Kulakundis
gallery, which you,
yourself made.
But which kind of leads
me back to the models.
And I just wanted to ask, when
you encountered the models,
well I guess this is a
question for all of you.
What went into the
selection process?
I guess could you tell
us a little bit more
about your fascination
with the models?
- When you first invited
me to do something here,
I wanted to reproduce the
Howe building at Radcliffe
and it was not practical.
So, I couldn't do it.
So then I sort of revisited our
visit, Hansel's and my visit
and going down in to
that tactile museum.
And I was thinking I
just wanted to bring,
make a kind of cabinet
of curiosities here.
But it was really the buildings
which were of interest.
And then when Lily
discovered that there
is this whole cache
of them in Ohio,
then that got really
exciting and so
there's a lot of them in Ohio.
Dozens, but they're
all in storage.
And so we chose the ones which
were the most travelable, which
were in the best condition.
And also to have sort
of a range of monuments
and then and domestic buildings.
- You've given them a
wonderful kind of new chapter
in their afterlife.
And Kim could you
say a little bit more
about the history of the
pedagogical use of the models.
Architectural models are
really, tactile models
are a really fascinating way
of understanding architecture
and scale.
- They actually absolutely are.
And I can remember
the first time
I actually got to look at one
of the WPA models at Perkins.
I didn't go to
Perkins as a student,
I went to another school for
the blind in another state.
And always wished while I
was in school that someday I
could go to Perkins,
never knowing
that one day I was going to
get a degree in library science
and become the Director
of the Library at Perkins.
So it was kind of a wonderful
story, but touching the models
and just knowing
the story of the WPA
and the craftsman
of the era that,
pulling those people together
to create such beautiful models.
And then, that's what
you'll get to experience
when you go to the gallery.
But it's so meaningful, because
the Parthenon for example,
is a very huge building.
And very challenging
to describe.
So I've always known that models
played a very important role
in teaching blind and
visually impaired kids.
Most of the time it had been
used for animals and things
like that, but having
buildings, cathedrals,
bridges is another thing that
we have several bridge models
at Perkins.
Because we've got a
bridge right here in town
that isn't all that old.
The Zakim Bridge, how do you
describe the Zakim Bridge
to somebody who has never--
How do you touch a bridge?
You don't touch a bridge.
You need a model.
And my other model experience
was the space shuttle.
I lost my vision when I was 11
and so that was before there
was a space shuttle.
I knew it was some
kind of little machine
thing that had these big
wheels and things like that.
But I didn't really know what
it did until I saw a model
at Perkin's.
So even these models are
phenomenally beautiful.
They're carved.
They're art in themselves.
But even a plastic model can
convey so much information
and using them.
Rockets and like you
said, you saw a rocket
in the tactile museum.
They really bring
home what an object is
and how it works by having
that opportunity to feel
the whole dimension of the
object or the building.
- One of the interesting
things about the models that we
discussed when we had
a walk through earlier,
was how it conveys
scale and texture.
Which is interesting because
Hansel, as you mentioned,
some of those wood components,
if they were scaled up properly
would be enormous pieces
of wood in relation to--
- Yeah, I find their
craftsmanship just really
compelling, because
of that play on scale.
Some of the houses are
made out of plywood
that we build our houses with.
So you'll have this wood
grain in this house that
would be, a strand
of wood would be
as big as my body
or a little nail
might be the size of this table.
There's just some way in the
craftsmanship that all of that
comes together.
That it really shows
the hand in the making.
And so, in some
ways, I find that one
of the most beautiful
parts of the model
is you see their making.
And I think that's another
way that this idea of touch,
it touches through
time that way.
And I think that I find them
really beautiful that way.
You'll notice some of
the models also will
have some variation in color.
And I think that, this
is my own suspicion,
but I think that was
the craftsmen who
are looking at the idea
of high contrast of color
for people who are
low-vision to begin
to discern certain
building types or parts.
So they're playing with
that as well as texture,
the way they play in light.
On the idea of scale,
I'm certain I'm
wrong about this,
but I'm going to say it anyway.
You'll see that the Capitol
building is in there and then
the Washington Monument.
And they're almost
close enough in scale
that you could probably
set them up in the room
and see the relationship
between those two
in a way that would
help you understand
our national monument in a
way that you don't really,
when you're there.
And this is a place
I see everyday,
living in Washington DC.
So I think those
elements that we're not
accustomed to looking
at, these models really
show that really beautifully.
- There's a part of
the exhibit that I
want to be sure
people don't miss,
because it's not really
a model, but it is.
And it's outside
of the exhibit hall
itself, so make sure you
see outside the window
of the exhibit hall
when you're there,
that the trees on
the wall there.
They were made by the WPA.
They're labeled in Braille.
And they are
different tree species
in a two dimensional replica
made of wood on the walls.
So they're kind of fun, because
again, think about trees.
Even when you climb a
tree as a blind kid,
you're not going to get the full
sense of the shape of the tree.
So there's one particular
tree on that wall
that I told my
colleagues here, I
had no idea what a
poplar tree looked like.
So go look at a
poplar tree and you'll
see why I was so mystified
at what it looked
like when I touched it today.
- And they have
small figures carved
in the bases of the trunks.
Do give you a sense of scale.
- Yes, that represent a person.
So you can see the scale
with the little person
at the bottom, you can feel it.
- And the models are decidedly
not architectural models.
I was talking with Hansel
about this, being an architect.
But architectural
models are made
to sell an idea to a client.
And these are not made to
sell an idea to a client.
They're made to be
touched and to be handled.
And so in some ways, they
resemble doll's houses,
dollhouses a little
bit more than they
would an architectural model.
- Yeah and I reminded
Wendy that one
of the travesties I
think is certainly
in architectural education
when I went to school
is learning how to make models.
One of the first things
they tell you is you're
not making a dollhouse.
This is about architecture.
It's about the concept.
We talked about that
earlier this afternoon
and it just now kind
of dawned on me.
Again here, that's kind
of like teaching children
not to draw these,
to be creative.
Color between the
lines kind of idea.
And I think there
again, there's embedded
in our educational system is
this idea that you shouldn't
touch.
You shouldn't make models that
you want to break or touch.
So I think this idea of going
back and rebuilding dollhouses.
I think we should
re-introduce that.
- The models certainly
look like they're,
as you said, they're meant to
be touched and that's Wendy,
why you wanted to make your own
model rather than Commission
someone else to make it.
- Right, at first
Meghan had offered
that that the architectural firm
that designed the space, maybe
they could make the model.
And so I went to
visit their offices
and looked at their models.
And there's like, no.
There was a completely
different everything.
Different style.
- Well it's not
quite architecture,
but there is this
wonderful anecdote Kim,
that you told about how
tactile engagement helps
to kind of allow one
to know an object
and it concerns one
of your trips to I
believe it was Hawaii.
You said, when you were
given a tour of a ship.
And I was wondering if you
could kind of just relay that.
- Oh I'd love to
share that story.
- Very pertinent to my what
we're talking about here.
- My husband and I, my
husband's in the front row here.
And we were traveling
in Hawaii and we
were with a man who had been
very much involved in bringing
the USS Missouri to Honolulu
as a permanent museum for World
War II.
And he took us on
a tour of the ship
and showed us a lot
of different things.
And we were on the
main deck and he said,
the kamikazes would
crash their planes
into the side of the
battleships trying to sink them.
And that there was a
place on the Missouri
where that had happened.
And I asked how far down
from the deck it was.
And he said it's
about 12 inches down.
And so I said, can I touch it?
And he said, well sure.
So I got down on the ground
and put my hand over the edge
and felt the dent in the side
of this battleship that I was on
and it brought it
to life for me.
But what really brought it
to life was when I stood up,
I said to him, have
you ever touched that?
And he goes, no I haven't.
I said, well do it.
And he got down on
his knees and he
felt it and he sounded like
he had tears in his eyes
when he stood up.
He said, I've been on
this ship dozens of times
and I never did that.
And that meant so much
to me, so there's just
that whole extra level
of the sense of touch
and what it can bring
to the occasion.
- This is so interesting,
one of the things
that really again
kind of permeates
the exhibition is this
relationship between language
and the other senses, and
tactility in particular.
And it's both manifest
in the Beaufort Wind
Scale and the relationship
between verbal description
and visual description.
But also in the very handouts
and postcards for the show,
which are printed
in Braille as well.
And was something I think we
were talking about earlier.
But it's something
I think that was
particularly important for
us to do for the show Wendy,
could you elaborate
a little bit on--
- Well, for the
card for the show,
it was really
important that this
be something that could be read
by someone who read Braille,
as well as by someone
who read Roman letters.
And so the Braille
is superimposed.
They're imprinted right
on top of the other.
And so, it can be read equally.
And I just love that sort
of simultaneous translation,
one right on top of the other
and it doesn't, neither one
interrupts the other.
- And even for those of
us who don't read Braille,
it's kind of a very appealing,
kind of moving thing,
to be able to feel
it in our hands.
Re-sensitizes us
to our fingertips.
- Yes you just hold the card
and it's like oh, something
is different.
- Sensory objects.
Well, we're pretty much
out of time for the panel.
So, what I wanted to do was now
invite everybody again with us,
to move to the
neighboring Byerly Hall
to join us for a reviewing of
the show and the reception.
But before that to join me
in thanking our panelists
[INAUDIBLE]